c і ви бог дав і не
не буду зайнятий у момент падіння
пасажирського літа до малайзійських
авіаліній ті кадри російської то лобач і
я показала вже за кілька хвилин після
трагедії так сам жарт які інтерв'ю
зубною святвечір та в апараті steel
Олександром Бородай м судячи з усього
чи справді не сумнівається щілини так
був збитий українськими ризиковими та
і удача я у тему тіла з прямого на
провокації українці вже не вперше як ви
знаєте збивати пасажирський літак
офіційний київ відра запалять кидаючи
такі званого чині це потрапляє за видом
її заскоки на російських
сепаратистів ще й на завершивши 8 с
прем'єр-міністром болоньї
давай випадку види міні україни запити
ланських архів тирекс партію до прозора
відкритого розслідування всі терористи
чінават хоче повернути вашу маму
schematic унцію звана не інцидент
на катастрофу і точно міністерству
оборони України і навіть дали і прямо
заявляючи вологий російський slide
застане немає вже 3 трагічний ви
paddock після того я російська
території було збуто такі ан-26
су-25
з бронях сил України ми не вимикаємо і
рахунок селі так такий так ваш бог збитий
сепаратистів ж за я був ще вивчили на
місці катастрофи бортові самописці
розслідуванням оазису вати за eg їх
обставлений тягли even і заглянув і ми ж
три сотні пасажирів шип ремували за
майстер будинку діставайте малайзії